Ich bin der Herr von der Bahn, ich bin auf die Station als Assistenzarztin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Na klar, gerne.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich ein paar gewane Fragen stellen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Helmut Schmidt.
Ich bin der Herr von der Bahn, ich bin auf die Station als Assistenzarztin tätig und werde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Mein Nachname ist Eswin Siegfried, für die Station als Assistenzarztin tätig und werde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Danke Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,68 m und ich wiege ungefähr 56 kg.
56 kg, okay.
56 kg.
Okay.
Pro Sam ist es so wenig für Sie.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Schmidt, wie kann ich Ihnen ein Haarphone?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich zunehmende Luftnot habe, die ich nicht wegbekommen.
Ich bin sehr platt, ich bin sehr müde und ich bekomme diese Luftnot.
Die wird immer schwieriger, schlimmer bei mir.
Diese Luftnot sind heute aufgetreten, ja?
Nein, nicht heute, die habe ich schon länger.
Heute Morgen war das sehr, sehr schlimm.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Wäsche werden?
Mehrere Monate schon.
Halben Sie auch Husten?
Morgens, jeden Morgen habe ich Husten.
Und der macht mir sehr zu schaffen.
Halben Sie Husten mit Ausbruch?
Es ist eher so ein trockener Husten.
Meistens kommt ein Schleim, wenn ich einmal abhuste, dann ist er wieder besser.
Es dauert lange, bis ich diesen Schleim komplett abhusten kann.
Aber es ist eigentlich ein trockener Husten.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie Warns am Fieber?
Ob ich Fieber habe?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Ja, haben keine Fieber.
Haben Sie Brust, Schimmars?
Wenn ich Hust, ja.
Beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Wenn ich Husten.
Husten, wenn Sie Husten, ja.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Sind Sie schmarsen?
Ja, ich bin auch der Brust.
Wenn Sie einatmen, dann sind Sie auch der Brust.
Okay.
Wie viele Schwerden haben Sie?
Ich bin sehr müde.
Ich habe nicht mehr die Kraft wie früher.
Ja, ich bin nicht mehr so fit wie früher.
Wie viele können Sie laufen?
Ich habe nicht mehr die Kraft wie früher.
Ja, aber ich habe auch Luftnoten.
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr Luftnoten.
Also, wenn ich bei der Grenze,
wenn ich bei der Grenze,
wenn ich den Luftnot mehr zu bottom bin,
ist es ganzumsyavioral.
Aber wenn ichocusedere,
hofendim ich aber Japazien.
Bei eigentlicher Belastung habe ichedom leichte Luftnoten.
auf Kraftlosigkeit. Fühlen Sie sich in allgemein sehr erschöpft auf?
Ja genau, das erschöpft natürlich mich ja.
Wie ist der Appetit Herr Schmidt?
Eigentlich gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen, ich meine damit ungewollte?
Ich habe abgenommen, tatsächlich, ich habe um über 6 kg abgenommen.
6 kg?
6 bis 8 ungefähr.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher.
In welchem Zeitraum wissen Sie?
Ja, so 2 Jahre ungefähr.
2 Jahre.
Okay.
Ich bin ein etwas ungewöhnliches Bemarkt.
Sie haben schon Kraftlosigkeit.
Also, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, ich werde wirklich die letzten Jahre sehr aufs Kranken.
Sehr aufs Kranken.
Sie haben immer Erkältungen, Erkältungen.
Ganz oft.
Ganz oft, okay.
Insbesondere im Winter, ha?
Immer Lungenentzündung haben Sie?
Ne, Lungenentzündung glaube ich nicht.
Ich fühle mich krank, krippe, Erkältung.
Und da bin ich auch so aus dem Land.
Viel Schnupfen, viel Husten.
Okay.
So, seit hab ich es ja auch kopfisch machen, oder grip, ernihezeptome.
Eine was?
Moment, moment.
Hab ich es ja auch kopfisch machen, oder grip, ernihezeptome.
Nein, Moment, ich fange nicht.
Momentanis.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich gut, aber ich habe jetzt in den letzten Tagen zunehmend diese Luftnot.
Und die macht mir Sorgen.
Weil das mich in meinem Leben sehr einschränkt.
Also, wenn ich jetzt aufstehe und ich möchte jetzt das Haus putzen, oder ich fahre zur Arbeit,
oder bemerke ich, dass ich sehr schnell Luftnot habe.
Wie herrschimm ich?
Können wir sie flahre Gönnenh Track schlafen?
Oder wie fühlt es uns um das zu können, wie wir sie behinden.
Hbellen sie?
Nein, nicht, das ist sofort.
Haben Sie geschworener?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Schmid, Sie haben eine andere Sache.
Nein.
Haben Sie das alles direkt oder alles klopfen bewirkt?
Ja, wenn ich das oft trenne, habe ich das oft.
Schwitz sind Sie öfter als früher?
Nein.
Nein, ohne Schwitz.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Stufros? Nein.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, ich möchte über die Erfahrung von der Corona-Konvention kommen.
Ich habe keine Corona-Konvention.
Nein, das ist so. Okay, sehr gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden, Herr Schmidt?
Ja, also früher habe ich mein Bild aus.
Was ist das?
Ich war 20 Jahre alt.
Das ist schon über 50 Jahre alt.
20 Jahre alt oder 20 Jahre alt?
Ja, ich war 20 Jahre alt.
Also, das ist schon sehr lange.
Haben Sie eine Operation?
Nein, okay.
Wie viele Regeln haben Sie von der Corona-Konvention?
Ich habe nicht mehr mehr.
Ich habe keine Gruppe, ich nehme schon immer Popen ein.
Ich bin jetzt etwas projert mit der Corona-Konvention.
Nein.
Warum Sie für Ihre aktuellen Bescheidung beim Hausarzt?
Ja, ich war vor einigen Monaten da, weil ich den Krippbe hatte.
Und er hat mir dann Medikamente aufgeschrieben, Antibiotikum aufgeschrieben, dann war das weg.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, warum Sie allerginen oder unverteilt nicht gehalten?
Ich habe eine Hausstauballägie und Verträglichkeiten habe ich nicht.
Wie reagieren Sie dagegen oder darauf?
Jugendkreis, Niesen, so was in der Arbeit.
Okay. Herr Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
20 bis 25 Zigaretten.
25 Zigaretten?
Ungefähr ja.
Seit wann?
Ich habe früh angefangen, also mit 17 Jahren habe ich angefangen.
Mit 17 Jahren?
Ich habe es schon lange jetzt ja.
Mhm.
Terinkunze Alkohol?
Nelten, selten, vielleicht ein, zwei Mal im Monat vielleicht.
Was können Sie?
Bier oder Wein.
Ein, zwei Mal im Monat, ein oder eine Fleisch oder ein, zwei Glas.
Ja, Flasche nicht, geht da ja.
Okay. Herr Schmidt, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht,
das ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein.
Herr Schmidt, möchte ich jetzt auf Ihren aktuellen Becher werden,
Sie rücken Sie?
Habt ihr das Probleme?
Was ist das für Sie?
Nein.
Ja, das ist kein Durf, das ist ein Durf.
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Müssen Sie sich häufig auf die Toilette gehen, in der Nacht?
Auch nicht.
Auf nicht, okay.
Also jeden Tag, jede Nacht einmal.
Aber ich war beim Urologen gewesen und der meinte,
wenn das okay ist, wenn ich keine Probleme habe,
wäre das kein Problem für mich.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Ich möchte jetzt die Familie in Anamnese anfangen.
Ich bin jetzt in der Familie, in der Corona-Kranken,
ich meine, die Bluthochdruck, Krebs-Arkankranken.
Ja, meine Brüder hat Bluthochdruck, meine Brüder hat auch Zucker.
Mhm.
Sie sind hier auf der Toilette?
Wir sind gestorben beide.
Wir sind gestorben, es ist mir sehr leid.
Wann war, oder wann war nun sie gestorben und woran?
Also meine Mutter, die ist in einem Schlaganfall verstorben.
Mhm.
Und mein Vater, da wissen wir nicht, warum er verstorben ist.
Er war einfach tot.
Mhm.
Einfach, okay.
Wie art war es in der Irakstan, wenn sie gestorben sind?
Die sind beide jung gestorben, die waren beide so um die 50.
50.
Nach einander, ja.
Einander, das ist sehr schwierig für sie.
Ja, mit meinem Bruder wollen wir denn alleine irgendwann.
Mhm.
Halbungsjahr sind auch andere Schwester, nur ein Bruder?
Nur ein Bruder habe ich.
Mhm, okay.
Herr Schmidt, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden, mhm.
Okay, halbungsjahr sind Kinder.
Ich habe eine Tochter, ja.
Eine Tochter, mhm.
Sind Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja.
Mhm.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Schneider.
Schneider, mhm.
Ich arbeite in einer Textilfabrik.
Textil, okay.
Halbungsjahr sind Sie auf der Arbeit?
Ja, wir haben das nicht.
Jeder hat Stress.
Das ist das, dass diese Stilfabrik belastet ist, oder sie zufrieden ist?
Eigentlich bin ich zufrieden.
Mhm.
Ich bin schon sehr lange in der Fabrik.
Herr Schmidt, ich bin ein bisschen schon fertig,
möchte etwas hinzufügen, oder möchte andere Bescheiden.
Davon ich wissen sollte.
Was habe ich eigentlich nicht?
Ich habe nur diese Luftnoten, die mich stört.
Mhm.
Und die mich einschränkt.
Ja, Sie haben Luftdont bei Belastung auf, ja, insbesondere bei Belastung.
Sie kommen nicht wie attacken, ja.
Sie haben auch keine Allergen.
Aber Sie haben trotzdem in der letzten zwei Jahre abgenommen.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig, die Information für mich.
Ja.
Ja, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Was passiert jetzt mit mir?
Was haben Sie vor, was soll gemacht werden?
Ja, Herr Schmidt, ich werde jetzt sehr körperlich untersuchen.
Ich brauche ein paar Untersuchungen, insbesondere Labo,
operative Diagnostik, ja, wir geben eine Verfahrung.
Perfekt.
Ja, wir brauchen so erst Röntgen, ihr Arlbrust, ihr Arlunge.
Dann habe ich gegeben, falls die andere Untersuchungen,
Masanen, die ich durchführen werde.
Aber ich werde sie detailiert untersuchen, okay?
Was ist das für eine Röntgen?
Sie müssen, ich glaube, das im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja, wir brauchen weitere Untersuchungen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, werde ich sie informieren.
Es geht um ihre Röntgen, deswegen brauche ich ein paar Untersuchungen.
Kann das auch das Herz sein, oder ist es auf jeden Fall die Lunge?
Ja, es kann auch Herz sein, aber ich fokussiere so erst die Röntgen.
Okay.
Soarß die Röntgen, die ich auf der Röntgen,
natürlich. Ja, Herz ist sehr wichtig, deswegen werde ich auch weitere Untersuchungen
durchführen, ja, wie EKG, Herzaktivität und so weiter.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie viele Stunden arbeiten Sie pro Tag?
8.
Und haben Sie Luftschmutzung in Arbeitsplatz?
Hab ich was?
Luftschmutzung.
Luftverschmutzung.
Was ist schlecht gelüftet da?
Sticke Luft.
Vielen Dank.
Einige Kollegen fragen, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja.
Ich bin selten beim Hausarzt, ich weiß das nicht.
Also ich bin nicht so oft beim Arzt eigentlich.
Deswegen, ich glaube ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich bin nicht so oft beim Arzt.
Ich habe aber auch keine Vorsorgeuntersuchungen gemacht.
Ja, vor einem, vor einem, einige Monaten haben Sie gesagt,
dass Sie Ihren Hausarzt behandelt wurden.
Ja, ich war da wegen einer Grippe, der hat mir Antibiotikung verschrieben
und gesagt, das geht nach fünf Tagen weg, dann war es auch weg.
Der hat mich abgehört mit seinem Stethoscope
und hat mich wieder nach Hause entlassen.
Ich habe mich fünf Tage bekannt geschrieben und dann war alles wieder gut.
Haben Sie Luftfunktionstests gehabt?
Ein Was?
Luftfunktionstests.
Ja.
Ist bei mir noch nie gemacht worden.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wer das macht.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen
oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein.
Ich stehe nur einmal nachts auf und gehe auf Toilette.
Ich sehe alle Fragen, die ich zu dir tässt,
könnten wir als erstes zu sprechen beginnen.
Ich habe eine Frage, die ich für die Luftfunktionstests gemacht habe.
Was ist das?
Luftfunktionstests.
Nein, das ist nicht das.
Okay.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen
und würde gerne mit Ihnen diesen Fall besprechen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herr Schmidt.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt, 1,68 m groß
und hat seit 58 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Schmidt, ich stelle es heute bei uns wegen
der Wichtung des Luftfunktionstests
und der Fertigung des Luftfunktionstests.
Sie werden von mehreren Monaten aufgeholt,
aber sie werden jetzt noch nicht verwendet.
Sie haben einen原izierten Einwalt.
Nein, es gibt einen原izierten Einwalt.
Es gibt einen原izierten Einwalt.
Sie werden jetzt noch nicht verwendet.
und er klackte auf über Kraftlosigkeit und er erwähnte in der Listensite
die sich durch Prioritis und Renitis öussere. Der Patient sei Rafa, er Rafa 25, Zigaretum-Technik seit dem 17. Jahr, 17. Lebensjahr.
Er trinkt 17 Lebensjahr. Er trinkt Zertenalpohol, Noah, ein bis zweimal Promenat, Wein oder Bier,
Hypertony und Diabetes Militus.
Der soziale Anamnese gab den Patient an, dass er geschieden sei und habe eine Tochter.
Er hat die Tochter von Beruf und er arbeitet in Textilfirma.
Er hat leichtes Stress bei der Arbeit und zufrieden sei.
Er ist nicht unklar, er hat viel zu tun, aber kann ja noch mehr.
Der Patient hat Gewicht verrost, er ist Rafa und er ist auch eine schwere Patientin.
Er ist der Patient von der Diabetes Militärin, der Hypertony und Diabetes Militus.
Er ist der Patient von der Diabetes Militärin, der Hypertony und Diabetes Militärin.
Er hat viel zu tun, aber kann ja noch mehr.
Natürlich meine Verdachtdiakose ist nun schon, deswegen werde ich die Nebenwarte, die Nierenwarte auch überprüfen, ob es Beteiligung gibt.
Gegeben anfalls, anfähle ich auf CT-Torax und so weiter.
Ja, also bevor Sie das alles machen, wäre vielleicht eine lungende Funktion, Untersuchung ganz wichtig.
Ja, für COPD, ja das stimmt.
Bevor man eine Lungenfunktion macht, bevor man eine CT-Torax macht, nicht direkt alles auf einmal.
Was können Sie in der Ambulanz noch machen?
Was kann man noch mal eine Blutgasanalyse?
Ja, Blutgasanalyse, auch sehr wichtig.
So wie ich das verstanden habe, ist der Patient sehr selten beim Hausarzt, generell bei Hersten.
Er hat keine Hematemesis, wie gesagt.
Er hat jetzt gesagt, dass er Gewicht verloren hat, in zwei Jahren, nicht von zwei Monaten, nicht mehr von zwei Jahren.
Das kann man haben, das ist nicht Besonderes.
Vielleicht war er schon immer so schlank.
Man sollte natürlich einen Bonchal-Kartchen umdenken, das ist gut, dass Sie daran denken.
Aber vorher sollte man gucken, ob er nicht erscheint, ja noch keine Lungenfunktion gemacht zu haben, irgendwo bei einem Hausarzt oder bei einem Lungenfunktionarzt.
Sollte man zuerst gucken, ob es nicht einfach eine COPD sein könnte, mit morgendlichen Husten, was typisch ist für eine COPD, mit den ca. 55 Packiers, wie er hat, mit 25 Zigaretten am Tag, auch mit der Textilfabrik, wo er arbeitet,
Stoffe, die auch so etwas begünstigen können, erarbeitet sich zum Freien zum Beispiel.
Ich würde erst eine Lungendiagnostik machen, Burgtyscopie, nicht sofort, vielleicht erst ganz am Ende irgendwann.
Und den Patienten vielleicht auch nicht sagen, dass er den Verdacht auf Bonchal-Kart-Cinom hat, sondern wir sagen einfach, wir glauben, dass sie eine Lungenerkrankung haben,
eine chronische Lungenerkrankung, und wir müssen da eine Blutgasanalyse machen, Blut abnehmen.
Wir machen einen Röntgen-Torax, wir machen einen Infektions-Test, wir machen einen Ultraschall des Herzens, um zu gucken, ob es eine Herzbeteiligung gibt oder keine gibt.
Und dann kann man gegebenenfalls noch ein CT-Torax machen.
Wie würden Sie diesem Patienten denn helfen?
Hat Luftnot, was würden Sie jetzt geben, den Sie so zu nehmen?
Ja, wenn die Patienten das noch hat, ja, werde ich natürlich Medikamente, Zerterepaneinheiten, so erst war die Sauerstoff-Setigung missen.
Und danach es gibt Medikamente gegen Bronchalkonstruktion wie WT2-Agonisten.
WT2-Agonisten oder Zarbutomol, weder Zarb-Agonisten oder Zarbutomol oder Sarmeterol, werde ich probieren.
Wenn diese Therapie nicht ausreichend ist, dann werde ich
Piratenisolone, Oral oder Intramanos.
Bei Akkultanschuk, aber auch bei Inhalativ.
Inhalativ auch.
Aber bei Akkultanschuk war die Intramanos...
Genau. Oral reichne, bauch meistens aus.
Orale Stoßkottison, Stoßtherapie.
Ja, das hört sich ganz gut an.
Was erklären wir den Patienten,
wie sie Erkrankungen sagen, wenn man eine COPD ist?
Wie würden sie den Patienten erklären, was er hat?
Was würden sie sagen?
Der Patient fragt sich, was habe ich?
Was sagen sie, die haben das und das?
Sagen sie mal.
Okay, ich artiläre dann Patienten ja,
die haben die Momentanzen COPD, chronische Obstruktive,
Krankheit, brontherkrankheit.
Das heißt, das ist irrevisible.
Nicht heilbar.
Nicht heilbar und irrevisible, brontherkonstruktion.
Das ist eine Verengung der Bronzchen.
Verengung der Bronzchen.
Verengung der Bronzchen führt zu Beschwerden, Atmung und so weiter.
Ich empfehle den Patienten mit dem Rauben aufzuhören,
weil es ist auch sehr wichtig,
weil wir diese Krankheit kontrollieren, unter Kontrolle halten.
Mit dem Rauben aufhören.
Sie müssen ihm sagen, dass es nicht heilbar ist,
dass er, wie sie schon sagten, die beste Therapie ist Nicotin Karenz.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Ja, das hört sich gut an.
Und sie sagen, er soll regelmäßig zum Lungenfacharzt gehen.
Regelmäßig zum Lungenfacharzt, okay.
Regelmäßige Kontrollen.
Haben Sie schon mal, aha, Symptomatik gehört, aha.
Aha, das ist das,
das ist das, das ist das, das ist das.
Ja, typisch für chronische Bronzchen ist natürlich.
Aber nun ist ich habe Fokussiart, Fatigue und Kraftmusik,
und deswegen habe ich schlimmste, an schlimmsten Möglichkeiten denken.
Natürlich, ich hoffe, dass sie das einhalten müssen
oder erst eine Diagnose ziehen.
Wenn der Patient jetzt gekommen wäre und gesagt hätte,
ich habe eine bekannte COPD, dann hätte man weiter denken müssen
und sagen, okay, er könnte auch ein Lungenfacharzt
nummer entwickelt haben natürlich.
Was bedeutet Nuha?
Nuha.
Es gibt eigentlich eine Klöpfskalsion, ich weiß es nicht.
Nuha, Nuha.
Die Leute, die Klöpfskalsion oder Einteilung für Bronzchen,
die COPD, die.
Nuha, und dann erklären Sie diesen Kardiologe.
Nein, nein, Petition.
Für Herzinfektionseintalung, okay.
Okay, ja, ich meine.
Ich meine, 2, 3, wie stark die Belastungsdispelös,
wenn Sie Treppen steigen.
Ja, ich meine, ich werde frei, dann am Ende,
in Ruhe auf.
Nein.
Ich meine, ich werde für.
Neha, für die Klöpfskalsion ist ein Schema
zur Einteilung der Herzinfektions.
Okay.
Und deswegen, der, welcher ist das?
Darf ich?
Ja.
Nein, nein.
Für diesen Fall.
Ja.
Bei Belastungsluftnote, ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
das wegen der Erste, das ist das,
ist das, weil der Herr.
Ja, Nuhaduray.
2, 3.
Ja, bei geringster Belastung,
bei der Belastung.
Ja, ja, auch in Ruhe.
Haben Kollegen noch eine Frage.
Immer dran denken bei Luftnot-Patienten
in der Notaufnahme, eine DGA,
Blutgasanalyse, mit der Blutabnahme zusammen
direkt machen zu lassen.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Weil so ist es.
Asylos oder Alkulos müssen wir beurteilen.
Und natürlich ist es wichtig.
Ganz genau. Einfacher Fall.
Aber Trostal.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.